[SAWING]
DAN STEINGART: I try as much
as possible to encourage
exploration and hacking and
throwing a lot of spaghetti
at the wall and then kind
of seeing what underlying
physics come out of that.
We don't just make things
randomly but we go with hunches
and if see that hunch works
and refine it, refine it,
refine it.
Right.
So it's not that
it's smaller this.
It's not that's
bigger in the AA.
I'm Dan Steingart.
I'm an assistant professor in
the Department of Mechanical
and Aerospace Engineering
and the Andlinger Center
for Energy and the Environment.
[TAPPING]
I study everything that
has to do with a battery.
Its materials, its packaging,
its power electronics,
and its failure.
So my lab is set up
to make new materials,
put those new materials into
batteries in various ways
because how you put the
battery together matters a lot,
make batteries of different
sizes, test those batteries,
beat them up, kill them,
and then dissect them
and look at them.
And then repeat the cycle again.
If this is true and R is
constant, then pV/RT equals 1.
The challenge in
teaching and I think
the benefit is
structuring right —-
so student's time is valuable.
Students want to get a
lot done, particularly
Princeton students,
but they also
want to own things and
truly understand things.
And when you do it right,
you structure a problem
in such a way that when the
student gets the answer right
or sees the answer unfold,
either in their brain
or on the piece of
paper in front of them,
they have an aha moment and
they take ownership of it.
I hope that the
students take away
an understanding of
how to diagnose and fix
complex systems.
And something that my Ph.D.
adviser instilled in me I think
is really important is not
to make the perfect the enemy
of the good.
So as Ivy League
students, everyone
tries to get the
A or the A plus.
But when you're
developing things
and you want to introduce
a product to the world,
the world has to have time
to respond to that product,
then you have to have time
to respond to the world.
And if you wait for
perfection, you're
never going to release anything.
We make things, we break things,
we study why they've broken,
we try to make them better.
And I try to make those cycles
as tight as possible and codify
that process.
So if students can
diagnose things,
fix them, and make them better,
and if they can simply do
that when they leave my lab,
I'm happy.
MIKE WANG: Dan wants
us to be independent
and he also wants us to have
the freedom to do what we want
and to pursue what
we're interested in.
He'll try to point
us in some direction,
tell us a cool idea he has.
If there's one thing
that I would take away
from working with him is that
there's always a creative way
to do things and a
novel way to do things.
DAN STEINGART: Princeton allows for
a lot of creativity.
People generally don't think of
engineers as creative people.
But my colleagues
and my students
are among the most creative
people I've ever met.
And I've not seen a maximization
of resources like this
anywhere else I've been.
I try to have my students
leading the projects
and looking at me like an old
man that's behind the times.
But by the time they're in
their second or third year here,
I want to be outdated and
baggage by the time they leave.
So if they're not
teaching me things
by the third or fourth year,
I'm doing something wrong.